hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so continuing on with
our matrix series of videos we're going
to be talking about how to solve
equations using inverse matrices so take
a look at the system of equations you
probably learned how to solve systems
using elimination methods substitution
graphing all those different techniques
but here we're going to do is we're
going to actually make this into a
matrix equation and solve it using
inverse matrices so first thing I'm
going to do is I'm just going to write
this as a matrix equation first I'm
going to do is I'm going to write the
coefficients in front of the variables
okay like so so you can see this is one
X negative 2 y 3 X positive 1 Y then I'm
going to write the variables x and y and
then I'm going to write the solutions as
a matrix negative 3 5 ok so are you with
me so far
if you take this row times this column
you get 1 X plus negative 2 y equals
negative 3 and that gives you back the
first equation same thing with the
second equation so we've just written
this as a matrix equation now you can
think of this as matrix a variable
matrix ax solution matrix B if we want
to get the variable by itself what we
want to do is we want to multiply by the
inverse of this matrix to both sides of
the equation now we talked about how
multiplication of matrices is not
commutative so if you multiply here on
the left you want to multiply here on
the left okay that's the key so you want
a multiply the inverse of this matrix
times a that's going to give the
identity matrix okay the identity matrix
is like the number 1 1 times anything is
going to be itself and you're going to
get the variable matrix by itself so all
we have to do is take the inverse of
this matrix times our solution matrix
okay a inverse times B that'll give us
our variable matrix and that'll be the
point of intersection for our two lines
so we'll have solve the system so what's
the inverse of this matrix well first
thing we want to do is we want to find a
determinant so that's 1 minus negative 6
which is 7 okay then what we're going to
do is we run up interchange the a and
the D but you can see that's not going
to make much of a difference and we're
going to make the B and the C the
opposite sign so that's 2 and negative 3
we're going to divide all those elements
by the determinant which is 7 so this is
our inverse matrix of a time's our
matrix B ok negative 3 5 and what we get
you can see is first row first column
that's going to be negative 3/7 plus 10
7 which is 7 7 or 1 and if you do for
this one the second row first column we
get 9 sevenths plus let's see plus 5/7
is 14 7 switch is 2 so you can see that
X is 1 and Y is 2 we can write our final
answer as a coordinate 1 comma 2 you can
check your answers by putting them back
into the equations but you'll see that
this is the common point of intersection
all right so you're with me so far let's
do one more example if you're enjoying
the videos subscribe to the channel and
keep on with a series of videos with
matrices but we'll do one more example
just to illustrate so what I mean so in
this example we're going to make this
one into a matrix equation we've got the
coefficients we have the variables and
we have the solutions 9 9 so all we need
to do here is take the inverse of this
matrix times the solution matrix to
solve for the variables so the determine
is 8 minus negative 1 which is 9 so what
we're gonna do is we're going to divide
all the elements okay by 9 we're going
to switch the a and the D so that's
going to be 4 and 2 or just switching
these we're going to make these the
opposite signs so this is our inverse
matrix times our solution matrix 9 9 so
if we take the first row first column we
get 36 9 minus 9 9 which is 27 ninths
okay our 3 and we get 9 9 plus 18 ninths
which is also 27 ninths or 3 so you can
see that the final result is 3 3 that's
where these two lines are going to cross
so again I hope you're enjoying the
videos subscribe to the channel and
continue on with this series of matrix
of videos and I'll talk to you in the
next video